hey guys i have another tip for you on
magnesium
uh i don't know if you know about
chlorophyll chlorophyll is the
blood of the plant it's the green stuff
right here okay
and chlorophyll is very similar to our
own blood but
the difference is we have iron and
chlorophyll has
magnesium so it's green it's a green
mineral
and magnesium is real good for
constipation
headaches leg cramps heart rhythmias
but it's used in over 300 different
enzymes in your body so it's it helps
protein metabolism
you name it so most people do not get
enough magnesium
so they have problems with sleep and
stress so i've been talking about
potassium but magnesium is the second on
the list
and the way you get it you got it
vegetables
so start increasing the quantity try to
shoot for
seven cups at least in the next week
each day
okay get your magnesium